hi i'm cam haines i'm a bow hunting
expert
and this is the breakdown
[Music]
this is game of thrones battle of the
have you seen bastards i don't think so
it seems intense whatever's gonna happen
oh
ooh got a little left he doesn't seem
too surprised
or too worried it's a little cocky i
like a longer bow because it's more
forgiving a short bow the wrist
the wrist position is going to affect
your accuracy back in the day
having a longer bow maybe gave them a
little more leeway on
like i said being forgiving he's getting
out their ways though this is going to
be tough ah
that's kind of weird let's go back a
little bit i mean that's weird head
position because
it's like he's moving his nose in the
way of the string there you want to be
looking at your target
and you want that string to go by leave
your face
unimpeded so for him it looks like it's
back here
then he kind of turns his nose into the
string it's not going to lend itself to
uh
to good shooting i don't think because
also you're changing your eye position
which
you want to keep your eyes fixed on the
target i don't know it's pretty weird
it's not surprising he missed this shot
it seems like we got something meeting
of energy here
nope too far bow hunting
in general is a close range endeavor i
feel pretty confident
40 yards and in but i practice a lot at
long distance so
there's people who are great shots
really dialed in with their equipment
they can shoot further
but i think for the general archer a 40
yard shot
is not 100 guaranteed every time best in
the world can shoot 100 yards
and getting further and further away too
he's not making it any easier on himself
so anytime i've run away from somebody
shooting an arrow at me which has been
zero thankfully but if that is ever
going to happen
i'm going to be zigging and zagging back
and forth i'm not going to run straight
in line straight away from the guy
shooting at me it's all that side to
side you know in football you want to
run north and south
not when somebody's shooting arrows you
want to run east and west
oh that one worked
god so that's surprising he's shooting
at a guy running away
he was close and he was way off way left
the second one
don't even know where it hit the third
one over the top so he's getting further
and further away
and then the last one when he's out
there a long way
through his heart i don't know about
that one yeah i would feel pretty
confident if i was a guy running away
seeing where those arrows would hit i'm
like i'm probably gonna be pretty good
here but
he wasn't he he took one to the old pump
station
this is rambo first blood part two
i've seen all these many times in first
blood
he fell had to stitch up his arm that
was badass he had the whole suture kit
in his knife so i wanted a knife like
that i know this scene right here let's
walk through it
looking just shredded john rambo is
shredded
do you often talk with your shirt yeah
oh yeah all the time
if i looked like that i would
freeze it right there a pistol at this
distance is tough to be accurate and
rambo has his bow but i don't think
that's a matter if you want
oh and look at the confidence see all
these scenes
it's confidence you see all these guys
they don't they don't
think they're gonna hit their target
they know they're gonna hit their target
rambo knows
this guy's days are numbered seconds are
numbered and this the old exploding tip
arrow
it looks like it's the case of a
razorback 5. they just kind of glued it
on there
it's kind of like what they came in
let's go back a little bit
so he's getting his arrow knocked up
there he's getting dialed in on his
target
he's got the bow canted a little bit
which is not typical
because he has sight pins on there those
are in straight line
so normally that top pin would be 20 the
second pin would be 30
then that bottom pin he has would
probably be about 60 or 70 yards but
because he's canting the bow it like
screws all that up so
i don't really know how he's aiming or
what his reference point is but i do
know he's got
hell obliques he's got a flat stomach
he's got the exploding tip broadhead on
there
and there's no doubt i think he's down
to one arrow though you see he doesn't
have any arrows in his quiver right
there
but it doesn't matter this dude's dead
rambo knows he's dead
the dude knows he's dead it's just a
matter of down the eyes and crossing the
t's
let's play that come on baby let him get
a little further away
this guy's feeling kind of like a mouse
and a field the hawks whooping down
and here comes whoo that hit home
there's pieces this piece is flat i
remember that rambo's not surprised
he is not surprised that that arrow hit
exactly where he wanted to hit
that's the confidence i'm talking about
okay you take a hot girl or a badass guy
you put a bow in their hand they're like
10 times hotter 10 times more badass
it probably started with rambo right
here we tried to do this actually
i shot an arrow through a propane
flame into a paint can and so i said hey
just testing out the new rambo
broadheads and people thought
that's what it was because it looked
similar to this there's flames and
explosions everywhere
i mean it exploded the hunger games
catching fire
jennifer lawrence she is responsible for
more young girls getting into archery
than
any woman in the history of women she's
controlled
she's consistent she's not flinching or
anything she can find that anchor that's
the key to
bow and arrow shooting is finding that
anchor so when you come to full draw
you want consistent anchor points so
like mine is the string comes across the
tip of my nose
there's a little metal uh knock goes in
the corner of my mouth
and then my hand's in the same position
every time so to be accurate you have to
have that those things exactly the same
every single time
with people attacking her like so
there's her rod head right there so
that's a two blade broadhead
cutting tip which means it starts
cutting from the very tip of the
broadhead
and it's a good edge on both sides you
can shoot lower poundage
and because it's sharp from the get-go
it starts cutting right when it hits
whatever the target is the broad head i
shoot it doesn't have a cutting tip on
it so it has to push through
first and then it starts to cut you kill
from hemorrhage so i have three blades
that are cutting as opposed to what she
has there is two blades so she's
starting to cut early but she's only
getting
a slice whereas i'm getting a hole a
slice is going to cause less hemorrhage
than a three blade hole i'm willing to
give up a little penetration
to get a bigger hole kind of graphic
fast forward a little bit
that is sweet i have yet to do a combat
roll that's not easy she shows some
athletic ability which i've always said
the best bow hunters are athletes too
i think she fits a bill there and it
worked i mean she's alive
the way this character started off with
hunting first and then transitioning to
hunting man no matter what you're
hunting with the bow you have to have
confidence in your equipment and
confidence in yourself it's why she's
successful in the woods providing for
her family and it's why she's successful
here in the hunger games also
good job jen this is brave
i am merida archers are always confident
she's got that fire in her eyes you can
tell right there
oh yeah range of motion she's having
she's being bound
down oh that's as that's as bull's-eye
as it gets we call that
hitting the x she's getting dialed in
here
excellent release oh that is a that is
money right there
pause it right here what you want to do
you want to draw back
and you don't want to be affected at all
on the release you don't want to flinch
you don't want to do anything
you want to stay exactly consistent and
watch that arrow hit the x just like she
did
i'm gonna guess this arrow might split
the other arrow on the x
oh now that's some penetration too she
might have drawn back a little further
on that just get a little more umph
we call that a robin hood right there
also you see that flex of the arrow
and that's what happens even with my
arrows the spine of the arrow
determines how stiff it is so you want
an arrow exactly matched up with the
poundage of bow you're shooting
if the arrow is under spined it's going
to be more like
a noodle being pushed by a bowling ball
way too much flex
if it's over spined it's gonna be too
stiff and it won't absorb that energy
right
so here's the arrow i shoot and
basically this arrow will flex i don't
know if you can see that
center of the arrow is about right here
so my arrow
is balanced front of center that's good
because that helps
get that weight out in front and this
arrow will steer better with that weight
here
this is called the fletch and brave as
we're watching this clip right here
that's feathers on her arrow
big feathers would steer an arrow better
with a broadhead
but have a lot of drag this has an iron
will broadhead on it this is
razor sharp actually even has my name on
it cam haynes
so that's kind of cool the perfect size
fletch the perfect broadhead the
perfectly tuned arrow
perfectly spined arrow if it all works
this thing can do amazing things
god it could be up to forty dollars for
one arrow that's why you always take
good shots you don't be losing these
this is animation but everything they
did here is a great representation of
archery
this is the killing season i haven't
seen this one so
normally i see good movies so i don't
know if this is a good movie or not
what oh my god i never thought i'd see
robert de niro
shooting a arrow at a bowl
uh kind of quartering too now that's not
the angle we want we don't want that
animal facing us we want broadside
i mean he's got pretty good form right
here his equipment
kind of sucks that rest is a whisker
biscuit a lot of people shoot them
just because they're cheap but they're
not super accurate at long range so i've
never even messed with one
the whisker biscuit has bristles that go
in and hold the arrow
so when that fletch goes through they're
hitting that you can actually cause the
arrow to hit because it's still being
affected by that rest all the way
through
when it leaves the bow right in front of
his eye that's open is the peep sight
and then that's what he's aiming through
the peep to the pin
to the animal my site is called a single
pin
so it's one post use a rangefinder i
figure out how far my target is and then
i
dial this yardage in the top um
reference point and then the bottom
reference point
correlate with that pin and that pin
what the hell is that you just spooked
him the fact that it spooked from radio
yeah that's realistic that's going to
sound like a rick in a garbage can
falling from
30 stories and hitting the ground
animals in general are used to sounds
in the woods or in the mountains they
can hear so well if they hear
something maybe 200 yards away a stick
break
they can tell right where that is if
they go through that area
later they'll remember i heard that
right there fast forward a little bit
how'd you know i was a manager because i
was there too
he ruined his bow that's why you wear a
safety belt in the tree stand right
there
if i fall i'm definitely taking the
brunt of that that i'm protecting my bow
and so he did a terrible job protecting
his bow because his bow got thrashed
he's not that young either i'm surprised
he didn't break a hip
he's still able to crawl crawl but crawl
too danger not good
didn't protect his bone not good i'd say
that's a
double fail this is king arthur legend
of the sword
how far can you shoot bill 75 no he said
107 that's a long shot with the bow so
75
did they say yards yeah yeah 75 yards
that's a even today
that's a good shot there's a youtube
video of me hitting a balloon at 237
i think world record at that time was
219 but i would think at that distance
there's going to be some other factors
they should weigh in if i shot in the
rain it'd be 10 yards short in the grass
because
the rain would be hitting the arrow down
and it would hit low if i have a slight
breeze going from left to right it's
going to push that arrow it sounds crazy
but barometric pressure at that distance
if the air is thick and humid and heavy
that arrow is just not going to fly the
same fast forward a little bit it's
about 175 yards isn't it
we can't see them they can't see us
oh my god look at these these arrows are
right in there that's some confidence
if you had a hill in between you and the
target or in this case maybe trees
you'd aim at the target and you'd know
that that is going to go
up and over and drop in maybe that's
what happened here but those arrows look
like they're very close together 175
yards two guys holding the target that's
impressive shooting
jump ahead please so that was practice
for this key moment right here i'm
taking it looked like he had some resin
he's getting when you're shooting
with fingers the smoother release that
can be the more straight that string can
come off the fingers
the more accurate it's going to be so
that's why he wants like baby powder
resin and something to where that string
slides right off the fingers that's
going to be key for shooting at this
distance do you use something like that
no i use a release so it's that release
on the sight hanging right there
yeah can you hear my arrow too
so what he's doing he's shooting with
fingers so he's shooting just like this
normally it's one string
one finger above two below and you pull
that back whereas my trigger release
here
it allows me to put on the string just
like this just so i
i don't adversely affect the string and
the release of the string
it has this trigger right here and it's
a perfect release doesn't have to go
around your fingers the arrow's coming
out of there perfectly straight
he's still focused he's ignoring the
noise
as an archer that's what you gotta do
you gotta be able to block out
everything else
because you gotta aim and it takes a
hundred percent focus so all those
distractions
you can see he's still he's still
looking at his target
good release it's a long shot he missed
him anyway
i didn't miss anyone that arrow blew all
the way through
even the animals i hunt big bear big
bull elk because
everything's working like it should i
got a razor sharp broadhead
it barely slows down going through the
animals and can actually stick in a tree
on the other side and that's what
happened right there the arrow went
through
had some blood dripping off of it he
took an arrow through the chest
and didn't really know what happened it
happened so fast
up next the avengers oh
it's a lefty you can have a laser sight
on a bow
it's just gonna be hard to see
especially in daylight at distance
of course it's hawkeye maybe hawkeye can
see it i'm all about delivering the
arrow and and making it lethal so if a
laser
sight allows you to do that at a higher
level then that's good for the animal i
want to be a merciful hunter
a lot of states don't allow electronic
equipment on your bow
so that would be considered electronic
equipment so it wouldn't be allowed in
some states for
for legal hunting but if it is and you
shop better and this is going to allow
you to be a higher level hunter
go for it he's got a finger tab on there
ah ooh that's not good
yeah he needs to have a little more umph
on that arrow it would have got to his
target a little faster with a little
more poundage probably but
the thing i noticed what uh jeremy
didn't have
i don't know about that anchor fingers
are away from his face right there
he's got the finger tab which guys shoot
finger tight because it's a little bit
smoother release than just fingers like
i don't know he i mean he looks
confident he looks so confident he's
like half smiling
but that anchor if it works for him
every single time then that's fine
that's gonna be a tough one to be
consistent it's kind of like a little
bit like katniss with hers below her
chin like that
this is a scene from the walking dead
season six
daryl he did some damage with his
crossbow in this series
he looks a little frazzled if he's gonna
be
shooting something with his crossbow he
needs to settle down and get more
focused
come on baby get your wits together holy
cow come on daryl
you're acting like you never took this
thing out of the bag see this is why you
practice in crunch time
see no it's the only problem i've ever
had with
uh with the walking dead is a rotten
zombie
and that arrow's only sticking in his
skull it should blow clear through that
it's not cinematic enough i guess
but if it sticks in his head i guess
that looks cool it shouldn't it
shouldn't even slow down
a crossbow can shoot over 300 feet per
second which is very fast
but the weight of the bolt is a lot less
because they're shorter than the weight
of an arrow so there's going to be less
kinetic energy
still plenty of kinetic energy enough to
blow through a rotten zombie school
but it's going to be less than say my
arrow coming out of my compound bow
as you saw darrell there pulled it out
of the bag the crossbow was cocked which
means the string's back
arrows loaded or they called a bolt in
my mind
bow hunting needs to be your point of
back it's under your power
i mean you can get good at shooting
crossbow in five minutes
because you can have a scope on there
just like a rifle get down
on a shooting bench aim at your target
and shoot at 100 yards and hit accurate
in five minutes with a bow that's going
to take
weeks months years for some people to
get that accurate with the
actual compound bow there's just a
different level of commitment
required between a crossbow and a
compound bow
but at least it's somebody shooting
arrows and daryl
made it famous that might be a conduit
to archery
and so i've looked at it as a positive
for uh for what i love
but man he struggled with that bag that
was not good i see where he needs to put
in reps
taking his equipment out of his bag
being ready to kill
up next the lord of the rings the
fellowship of the ring
dang he's like some rapid fire he's
getting it done right there
that's impressive i mean right to the
quiver arrow right on the string
no messing around it's going to take
reps to get
that good i mean that's like that's like
cat in a style right there you know
right to the quiver and it's like the
hand position was good
and then it went straight to the string
and straight back just doing that
boom boom boom shoot that's going to
take some time if this is what he does
this is what he's dedicating his life to
this is what he's known for
props that's uh that's a commitment i'm
impressed
let's go back a little bit you could
expect
a pass through with the target that
close depending on how what type of head
he had on there and how sharp it was it
probably would have went through his
intended target and maybe killed both of
them
if he was good enough which i would say
he's good enough but he could have done
a half draw
just enough to kill the bad guy but
that's another level of expertise but
wouldn't surprise me here rewind please
yeah the sound of those arrows coming
off the bow
not unrealistic because you think about
it an arrow
flying towards its intended target you
have the veins or the feathers on the
back
to steer the arrow the broadhead and the
feathers are essentially
cutting air and anytime you cut air like
that
it's making noise it's gonna make that
on the way to the target so it's pretty
realistic that's the thing about archery
and that's what i love about
all these clips is you see the
confidence you see the focus you can't
be
frazzled and make it a good shot so
you're in control of the moment the
moment doesn't control you
you're not hoping that arrow hits his
target you know for a fact it's going to
hit it
that's exactly what orlando's doing here
it's money it's impressive
i love it i love how archery is
displayed here is just like this
it's like effective weapon the display
of confidence is is very impressive
that's my breakdown of archery clips and
movies thanks for watching